ladies and gentlemen the vice president
of the United States and mrs. Cheney
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen Christopher DeMuth
president of the American Enterprise
Institute and Charles Krauthammer 2004
Irvin crystal Award recipient
[Applause]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we will begin by
singing America the my country tis of
thee god save the queen' version I know
that everyone I know that everyone
present knows the words by heart but for
those that would like a refresher the
words are printed in the middle of your
program we will be led by my ATI
colleagues
alexandra alaskan hacia dos 'va and
heather dresser please
[Music]
[Applause]
my country tis of thee sweet land of
liberty of the icy land of the pilgrims
pride from every mountainside let
freedom ring our father's gone to the
[Music]
Liberty to the ec
[Music]
to be bright with freedoms Holy Light
brought smart finite radar
[Music]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
please be seated
vice president and mrs. Cheney
colleagues and distinguished guests
welcome to the annual dinner of the
American Enterprise Institute for Public
Policy Research this is our largest
annual gathering since Ronald Reagan
gave his final major address in
Washington in December of 1988
I am deeply grateful to our many
generous sponsors especially our friends
at Pfizer and the members of our dinner
committee George Shultz was once asked
what is the most important qualification
for a senior position in government he
replied a high tolerance for ambiguity
presidents and cabinet secretaries only
get to make hard calls the easy calls
are made by others many decisions have
good arguments on both sides but the
really hard ones are those that combine
very large stakes with very large
uncertainties they call for intelligence
of a larger and more profound kind and a
determination not to lose a kingdom for
a shoe if we were to form a commission
of inquiry into every important Oval
Office decision made without the luxury
of waiting for more and better
information
there would be no more worries about job
creation in the service sector and in a
fractious democracy such as ours the
hard decisions are endlessly contested
in public debate in competition among
the three constitutional branches and
even within the executive branch itself
for us the biggest decisions are not
executive calls at all but rather a
process of continuous advocacy
compromise and adaptation
during the past 29 months America and
the free world have entered a new
political epoch whose defining features
are
precisely terribly large risks and
terribly large uncertainties especially
concerning the operations of our enemies
our political reef leaders have made a
series of momentous decisions and have
done so with great resolution their
resolution is all the more impressive
when one considers that the deficiencies
of information and of government
institutions designed for an earlier era
are better known to them than to anyone
else now their decisions and their
resolution are being tested in the
cauldron of democratic politics
tolerance for ambiguity is not a
predominant feature of partisan
campaigning but elections themselves
have clarified and fortified our foreign
policies to an impressive degree in the
past in the Cold War from the Truman
Doctrine to the Reagan doctrine our
enemies were demonstrating their WMDs
out in the open bragging about how they
would use them against us routinely
invading and subjugating other nations
and slaughtering civilians by the
millions still fashioning and sustaining
a political consensus was very hard and
contested from start to finish
many Americans sincerely believed and
argued vehemently that the root of the
world's problems was America itself but
we prevailed and we prevailed not in
spite of but because of the vigor of our
democratic practices and the sturdiness
of popular understanding can we do it
again in circumstances more shrouded and
insidious today despite stupendous
initial victories we are in the midst of
strenuous and necessary debates over
military and political strategy the
effectiveness of our intelligence and
diplomatic institutions and the
maintenance of fiscal fiscal discipline
and personal and economic freedom at
home but if we stand at the beginning of
another 50 year epoch a generational
commitment as Condoleezza Rice puts it
then we are still just getting started
still at the moment of creation
of new policies and new institutions for
facing the tasks and perils ahead that
the two men who are speaking to us this
evening have been present at the
creation is another great stroke of
American fortune one the recipient of AE
eyes Irving Kristol award for 2004 is a
man of thinking and writing the other a
former AEI Senior Fellow and vice
chairman of our board now vice president
of the United States is a man of
thinking and action Charles Krauthammer
his great contribution has been to see
through fogs of uncertainty in times of
upheaval he has grasped the essentials
of new problems while others remained
confused by incidentals more than once
he has provided us an intellectual
architecture that shows that what we
already know provides a sturdy
foundation for action Charles is also an
avid amateur chess player he is a
founding member along with AE eyes
charles Murray of one of Washington's
most exclusive secret societies the
pariah
chess club his Irving Kristol Award
consists of this exquisite John Jack's
mountain chess set and handcrafted board
our media which can take the silliest
people and ideas seriously often finds
truly serious men and women a bafflement
it is very funny to read the latest line
on Dick Cheney that this open and
engaging man who has expressed himself
on every manner of policy question in 30
years at the center of American politics
who has been Minority Whip of the House
of Representatives who has served in the
senior ranks of four administrations who
has become the activist vice president
par excellence is just now emerging from
obscurity getting around town attending
coming-out parties and plunging into the
thick of public debate at AEI we admire
people who think before they speak who
choose their words carefully and to
understand when the time for research is
Oh
and the time for decision has arrived we
are very honored that the vice-president
would continue to attend our councils
well on extended leave of absence
through 2009 or 2017
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight he is graciously agreed to
introduce our Irving Kristol lecturer
ladies and gentlemen the vice president
of the United States
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you all very much thank you Chris
and it's a pleasure tonight to join all
of you in honoring Charles Krauthammer a
man I admire very much and am proud to
call a friend the irving kristol award
is named for one great American and
tonight we bestow it on another Lynn and
I are pleased as well to be in the
company of so many other friends and
colleagues starting with Chris DeMuth
who does an absolutely superb job as
president of AEI
[Applause]
being here brings to mind my own days
affiliated with AEI which stretched back
some 30 years as a an officeholder
a freshman congressman an out-of-work
politician yeah remember the Board of
Trustees and the corporate official who
didn't appreciate how valuable the
experience was till I was asked to
contribute financially for the privilege
of being part of it but it has been a
very very important part of our lives
for me and and for Lynne and a very
important part of our intellectual
learning and development during our
years in Washington it's been a time at
AEI when I was a scholar a time when I
had an office a small staff and not much
in the way of actual responsibilities
turned out to be a lot like the vice
presidency
Lynne and I are truly grateful for our
many years of association with the
American Enterprise Institute
AEI has developed a reputation well
deserved for disciplined scholarship
intellectual integrity and fresh insight
into public policy an AEI continues to
earn that reputation every year with
research and writing of high standards
an ever increasing influence few at AEI
are more influential than the chairman
of our Board of academic advisors
professor James Q Wilson in last July
received the Medal of Freedom From
President Bush I've known Jim for a
number of years I've respected his work
ever since I was a graduate student in
the days when Lynn and I were both
working on our PhDs Lynn actually went
on to earn her PhD in British literature
I haven't quite settled on a topic for
my dissertation yeah
for me an expected career in academic
life was overtaken by a series of
opportunities in government and so I've
spent much of the last three and a half
decades in and around the city here
where our national debates are centered
you get used to the shifting attention
and the passing enthusiasms that
characterized so much of our political
commentary you learn to take it all in
and then to select out the well
considered judgments of a serious
thinker you begin to listen through the
chorus in search of that one clear note
and so often that clear note is the
commentary of Charles Krauthammer
this most respected of writers is also a
distinguished medical doctor who spend
years in practice as a noted
psychiatrist he first came to Washington
in the 1970s and soon found himself
working at the White House for one of my
predecessors and I now wish I'd paid
more attention at the time to the
speeches of Walter Mondale
because I'm sure they were absolutely
first-rate by the early 1980s Charles
Talent had been recognized by editors
and by readers in Washington and well
beyond and the most impressive aspect of
his work is the sustained level of
quality over a period of more than 20
years this is not a columnist who merely
fills space and meets deadlines Charles
Krauthammer always writes with care in
his columns and essays there is always a
powerful line of reasoning and behind it
the workings of a superior intellect
when you read his words you know you're
a dealing with a serious person who
assumes the same of you you see
something else as well in a Krauthammer
column whatever the subject at hand
Charles gives the reader evidence an
argument never just sentiment and the
conventional wisdom his great
intelligence is guided by principle and
an understanding of the world as it is
these qualities produce special insights
into the very areas where we need the
most from the new powers mankind has
assumed in science to the new dangers
confronting America and other free
nations a consistent theme in Charles
writings is his belief in human freedom
and his abhorrence for violence and
tyranny since September 11th Charles is
written compellingly on the urgent duty
of free nations to defeat the terrorists
and to hold to account any regime that
supports or arms them this war on terror
has in many ways brought out the finest
qualities of the American people and the
complexities of this era have certainly
brought out the finest attributes of
this writer his wisdom his deep moral
sensibility and his conviction that
freedom is the right of all mankind and
must be defended
the citation for the Irving Kristol
award for 2004 reads as follows the
Charles Krauthammer
fearless journalist wise analyst
and militant Democrat who has shown that
America's interest and ideals are
indivisible and that the promotion of
freedom is hard-headed realism I'm very
pleased that Charles wife Robin and
their son Daniel are here to witness the
presentation of this award and to see
the respect and the affection that we
all feel or its recipient my privilege
to introduce the great man we honor
tonight dr. Charles Krauthammer
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you mister
mr. Sleater
Thank You mr. vice president
Thank You mr. vice president thank you
for those very kind words I'm honored by
your presence here especially during
duck hunting season
and as a citizen as a citizen I want to
thank you not only for your leadership
and your wisdom during these
extraordinary times but for your courage
if Hamlet had borne half the slings and
arrows you have it would have been a
very short play seeing my checkered past
recalled in the program I'm struck by
how many places I have fled the
Democratic Party Canada and psychiatry
the trifecta
the reason I'm here ladies and gentlemen
is that I have nowhere left to go
I want to thank Christian Youth Jim
Wilson in the AEI Council for thinking
otherwise
and for bestowing upon me this great
honor particularly one that carries the
name of my dear and revered friend
irving kristol my subject tonight is
American foreign policy Americans have a
healthy aversion to foreign policy it
stems from a sense of thrift who needs
it we're protected by two great oceans
we have this continent practically to
ourselves and we share it with only two
neighbors both friendly one so friendly
that it's people seem intent on moving
in with us
it took three Giants of the 20th century
to drag us into it's great battles
Wilson into World War one Roosevelt into
World War two
Truman into the Cold War and then it
ended with one of the great ante
climaxes in history without a shot fired
without a revolution without so much as
a press release the Soviet Union simply
gave up and disappeared it was the end
of everything the end of communism of
socialism of the Cold War of the
European Wars it was the end of the
russian empire an empire which grew by
swallowing the equivalent of a belgium
every year for 200 years
given how brussels has behaved recently
overall not a bad idea
but the end of everything was also a
beginning on December 26 1991 the Soviet
Union died and something new was born
something utterly new a unipolar world
dominated by a single superpower
unchecked by any rival and with decisive
reach in every corner of the globe this
is a staggering new development in human
history not seen since the fall of Rome
it is so new so strange that we had no
idea how to deal with it our first
reaction in the 1990s was utter
confusion the next reaction was all when
Paul Kennedy who had once popularized
the idea of American decline saw what
America did in the Afghan war a display
of fully mobilized furiously
concentrated unipolar power at a
distance of 8,000 miles
he not only recanted he stood in wonder
nothing has ever existed like this
disparity of power he wrote nothing no
other nation comes close Charlemagne's
empire was merely West European in its
reach the Roman Empire stretched further
afield but there was another great
empire in Persia and a larger one in
China there is therefore no comparison
even Rome is no model for what America
is today first because we do not have
the Imperial culture of Rome we're an
Athenian Republic even more Republican
and infinitely more democratic than
Athens and this American Republic has
acquired the largest seeming empire in
the history of the world acquired it in
a fit of absent-mindedness greater even
than Britons and it was not just
absent-mindedness it was sheer
inadvertence we got here because of
Europe's suicide in the world wars of
the 20th century and then the death of
its Eurasian successor Soviet Russia for
having adopted a political and economic
system so inhuman that like a
genetically defective or
it's simply expired in its sleep leaving
us with global Dominion second we are
unlike Rome
unlike Britain and France and Spain and
the other classical empires of modern
times in that we do not hunger for
territory the use of the word Empire in
the American context is ridiculous
it is absurd to apply the word to a
people whose first instincts of hunt
arriving on anyone's soil is to demand
an exit strategy
[Music]
I can assure you that when the Romans
went into Gaul and the British into
India they were not looking for exit
strategies they were looking for entry
strategies in David Lean's Lawrence of
Arabia King Faisal says to Lawrence I
think you are another of these desert
loving English the English have a great
hunger for desolate places and indeed
for five centuries the Europeans did
hunger for deserts and jungles and
oceans and new continents Americans do
not we like it here we like our
McDonald's we like our football we like
our rock and roll and until 10 days ago
we liked our halftime shows
[Applause]
we've got the Grand Canyon in Graceland
we've got Silicon Valley in South Beach
we've got everything and if that's not
enough we've got to Vegas which is the
facsimile of everything what could we
possibly need anywhere else we don't
like exotic climates we don't like
exotic languages all those the
declensions and moods we don't even know
what a mood is we like Iowa corn and New
York hot dogs and if we want Chinese or
Indian or Italian we go to the food
court we don't send the Marines for
take-out that's because we are not an
imperial power we are a commercial
republic we don't take food we trade for
it which makes us something unique in
history an anomaly a hybrid a commercial
republic with overwhelming global power
a commercial republic that by pure
accident of history has been designated
custodian of the International System
the eyes of every supplicant from East
Timor to Afghanistan from Iraq to
Liberia Arab and Israeli Irish and
British North and South Korean are upon
us that is who we are that is where we
are and now the question is what do we
do what's a unipolar power to do the
oldest and most venerable answer is to
hoard that power and retreat this is
known as isolationism of all the foreign
policy schools in America it has the
oldest pedigree not surprising in a
country protected by two great oceans
isolationism originally sprang from the
view of America as spiritually superior
to the old world we were too good to be
corrupted by its low intrigues entangled
by it's cynical alliances today however
isolationism is the ideology of fear
fear of trade fear of immigrants fear of
the other isolationist want to cut off
trade in immigration and withdraw our
military entities
to commitments around the world even
isolationist of course did not oppose
the war in Afghanistan because it was so
obviously an act of self-defense only a
fool or a knave or a Susan Sontag could
oppose that but but anything beyond that
the isolationist suppose they are for a
radical retrenchment of American power
for pulling up the drawbridge to
fortress America isolationism is an
important school of thought historically
but not today not just because of its
brutal intellectual reductionism but
because it is so obviously inappropriate
to the world of today a world of export
driven economies of massive population
to flows and of 9/11 the definitive
demonstration that the combination of
modern technology and transient
transnational primitivism has erased the
barrier between over there and over here
classical isolationism is not just
intellectually obsolete it is
politically bankrupt as well four years
ago its most public advocate Pat
Buchanan who ran for president of the
United States and carried to Palm Beach
by accident
classic isolationism is moribund who
then rules America in the 1990s it was
liberal internationalism liberal
internationalism is the foreign policy
of the Democratic Party and the religion
of the foreign policy elite it has a
peculiar history it traces its pedigree
to Woodrow Wilson's utopianism Harry
Truman's anti-communism and John
Kennedy's militant universalism but
after the Vietnam War was transmuted
into an ideology of passivity
acquiescence and almost reflexive anti
interventionism liberals today proudly
take credit for Truman and Kennedy's
role in containing communism but what
they prefer to forget is that for the
last half of the Cold War
liberals used cold warrior as an epithet
in the 1980s they gave us the freeze
movement a form of unilateral
disarmament in the face of Soviet
nuclear advances today John Kerry the
boasts of opposing during the 1980s what
he calls Ronald Reagan's illegal war in
Central America and opposed he did what
was in fact an indigenous anti-communist
rebellion that ultimately succeeded in
bringing down sandanista rule and
ushering in democracy in all of Central
America
[Applause]
that boast reminds us how militant was
liberal passivity in the last half of
the Cold War but that passivity outlived
the Cold War when Kuwait was invaded and
the question was should the United
States go to war to prevent the Persian
the Gulf from falling into hostile hands
the Democratic Party joined the Buchanan
I'd isolationists in saying no the
Democrats have voted no overwhelmingly
two-to-one in the house and more than
four to one in the Senate and yet quite
astonishingly when liberal
internationalism came to power just two
years later in the form of the Clinton
administration it turned almost hyper
interventionist it involved us four
times in military action deepening
intervention in Somalia invading Haiti
bombing Bosnia and finally going to war
over Kosovo how to explain the amazing
transmutation of Cold War and Gulf War
dugs into Haiti and Balkan Hawks so
crucial and obvious difference is this
Haiti Bosnia and Kosovo were
humanitarian ventures fights for right
and good devoid of raw national interest
and only humanitarian intervention
disinterested interventionism devoid of
national interest is morally pristine
enough to justify the use of force the
history of the 90s refutes the lazy
notion that liberals have an aversion to
the use of force they don't they have an
aversion to the use of force for reasons
of pure national interest and by
national interest I don't just mean pure
self defense everyone believes in
self-defense as in Afghanistan I'm
talking about national interests as
defined by a great power shaping the
international environment by pride by
projecting power abroad to secure
economic political and strategic goods
intervening militarily for that kind of
Nash
interests liberal internationalism finds
unholy and unsupportable it sees that
kind of national interest as merely
self-interest writ large in effect a
form of grand national selfishness
hence kuwait no Kosovo yes the other
defining feature of Clinton foreign
policy was multilateralism which
expressed itself in a mania for treaties
the Clinton administration negotiated a
dizzying succession of parchment
promises on bio weapons chemical weapons
nuclear testing carbon emissions
anti-ballistic missiles etc why no
sentient being can believe that say the
chemical or by Allah you slit Senator
Joe Biden once defended the Chemical
Weapons Convention which even its
proponents admitted was unenforceable on
the grounds that it would quote provide
us with a valuable tool moral suasion of
the entire international community moral
suasion the point of this treaty was to
keep rogue states from developing
chemical weapons rogue states are by
definition impervious to moral suasion
was in moral suasion that made Qaddafi
see the wisdom of giving up his weapons
of mass destruction or Iran agree for
the first time to spot nuclear
inspections
it was the suasion of the bit the
bayonet
it was the ignominious fall of Saddam
and the desire of interested spectators
not to be next on the list
[Applause]
[Music]
moral suasion is a farce why then this
obsession with protocols legalisms UN
resolutions it's obvious net effect
after all is to temper American power
and reduce American freedom of action by
making it dependent on constricted by
subservient to the will and interest of
other nations but that you see is the
whole point of the multilateral
Enterprise to tie down Gulliver
with a thousand strings to domesticate
the most undomesticated most outsized
national interest on the planet powers
who after all was really going to be
constrained by these treaties in North
Korea today multilateralism remains the
overriding theme of liberal
internationalism when in power in the
90s multilateralism expressed itself as
a mania for treaties when out of power
in this decade it manifests itself in
the slavish pursuit of quote
international legitimacy and opposition
to any American action undertaken
without foreign blessing which is why
the democratic critique on the war on
Iraq is so peculiarly one of process and
not policy the problem was that we did
not have permission of the UN we did not
have large enough coalition we did not
have a second Security Council
resolution Kofi Annan was unhappy in the
French were cross the Democratic
candidates all say we should have
internationalized the conflict brought
in the UN and listed the Allies for two
reasons they say assistance and
legitimacy first they say we could have
used these other countries to help us in
the reconstruction this is rich everyone
would like to have more help in
reconstruction it would have been lovely
to have the Germans and the French in
Baghdad the Germans the qudoos the
policing the French could do the
catering
but the question is moot and the
argument is cynical France and Germany
made absolutely clear that they would
never support the overthrow of Saddam
so what comma dating that was not a way
to get them into the reconstruction it
was a way to ensure that they would
never be any reconstruction because
Saddam would still be in power of course
it would be nice if we had more allies
rather than less it would also be nice
to be able to fly but when some nations
are not with you on your enterprise in
including them in your coalition is not
a way to broaden it it's a way to
abolish it
at which point liberal internationalists
which appears and appealed to legitimacy
on the grounds that multilateral action
multilateral action has a higher moral
standing I have always found that line
of argument utterly incomprehensible by
what possible moral calculus does US
intervention to liberate 25 million
people
forfeit moral legitimacy because it
lacks the blessing of the butchers of
Chinaman's square or the cynics of the
Cade or say
which is why it is hard to take these
arguments at face value look we know why
liberal internationalist demanded UN
sanction for the war in Iraq it was a
way to stop the war it was the Gulliver
effect call a committee meeting of
countries with hostile or contrary
interests ie the Security Council and
you have guaranteed yourself another 12
years of inaction historically
multilateralism was a way for weak
countries to multiply their power by
attaching themselves to strong words but
multilateralism imposed on great powers
particularly on the unipolar power is
intended to restrain that power which is
precisely why France is an ardent
multilateral list but why should America
be why in the end does liberal
internationalism wanted to tie down
Culliver to blunt the pursuit of
American national interests by making it
subordinate to a myriad of other
interests in the immediate post Vietnam
era this aversion to national interest
might have been attributed to self-doubt
and self-loathing I don't know I leave
that question to a trained psychiatrist
what I do know is that today it is a
mistake to see Liberal foreign policy as
deriving from anti Americanism or lack
of patriotism or a late efflorescence of
sixties radicalism on the contrary the
liberal aversion to national interest
stems from an idealism a larger vision
of country a vision of some ambition and
nobility the vision of a true
international community and that is to
transmute the international system from
the Hobbesian universe into a Hokkien
universe to turn a state of nature into
a norm driven community to turn the law
of the jungle into the rule of law of
treaties and contracts and UN
resolutions in short to make the
international system in the image of
domestic society and to create such a
true international community you have to
temper transcend and in the end abolish
the very idea of state power and
national interests hence the antipathy
to American hegemony and American power
if you're going to break the
international arena to the mold of
domestic society you have to domesticate
it's single most powerful actor you have
to abolish American dominance not only
as an affront to fairness but as the
greatest obstacle on the whole planet to
a democratized international system
we're all live under self governing
international institutions and
self-reinforcing international norms
this vision is all very nice all very
noble and all very crazy and it brings
us to the third great foreign policy
school realism the realist looks at this
great liberal project and sees a
hopeless illusion because turning the
Hobbesian robot has existed since long
before the pellets that the
Peloponnesian wars into a Lockean world
turning a jungle into a subdivision of
the suburbs requires a revolution in
human nature not just a set of new
institutions but a revolution in hue
nature and realists do not believe in
revolutions of human nature much less
take their future and the future of
their countries upon them realism
recognizes the fundamental fallacy in
the whole idea of an international
system being molded on domestic society
first what hos domestic society together
is a supreme central authority wielding
a monopoly of power and enforcing norms
in the international arena there is no
such thing
domestic society may look like a place
of self-regulating norms but if somebody
breaks into your house you call 911 and
the police arrive with his guns drawn
that's not exactly self enforcement
that's law enforcement second domestic
society rests on the shared goodwill and
common values of its individual members
what values are shared by say Britain
Cuba Yemen and Zimbabwe all nominal
members of this fiction we call the
international community of course you
can have smaller communities of shared
interests NAFTA ends us the European
Union but the European conceit that
relations with all nations regardless of
ideology regardless of culture
regardless even of open hostility should
be transacted on the EU model of suasion
and norms and negotiations and solid
contractual agreements is an illusion a
fisheries treaty with Canada is
something real and agreed to Framework
on plutonium processing with the likes
of North Korea is not worth the paper it
is written on
[Applause]
the realist believes in the definition
of peace offered in the devil's
dictionary but Ambrose appears peace now
in international affairs a period of
cheating between two periods of fighting
hence the realist axiom the so-called
international community is a fiction it
is not a community it is a cacophony of
straining ambitions disparate values and
contending power
what does hold the International System
together what keeps it from degenerating
into total anarchy
not the phony security of treaties not
the best of goodwill among the nicer
nations in the unipolar world we inhabit
what stability we do enjoy today is owed
to the power and deterrent threat of the
United States
[Applause]
if someone invades your house you call
the cops who do you dial or someone
invade your country you dial Washington
in the unipolar world the closest thing
to a centralized authority to an
enforcer of norms is America American
power and ironically American power is
precisely what liberal idea what liberal
internationalism wants to constrain and
tie down and subsume in pursuit of some
brave new Lockean world realists don't
just live in America I found one in
Finland during the 1997 negotiations on
Oslo over the land mine treaty one of
the rare holdouts interestingly enough
was Finland the Finnish Prime Minister
stoutly opposed the landmine ban and for
that he was scolded by his Scandinavian
neighbors to which he responded heartily
that this was a very convenient pose for
the other Nordic countries after all
Finland is their land mind
that one usually takes about five
seconds it helps to have a map Finland
is the land mine between Russia and
Scandinavia America is the land line
between barbarism and civilization
where would South Korea be without
America and its landmines along the DMZ
where would Europe with its cozy
arrogant community be without America
having saved it from the Soviet -
Colossus where would the Middle East be
had American power not stop - Saddam in
1991 the landmine that protects
civilization from barbarism is not
parchment but power and in a unipolar
world American power wielded if
necessary unilaterally and if necessary
preemptively now those uneasy with
American power have made these two means
of wielding it preemption and
unilateralism the focus of unrelenting
criticism the doctrine of preemption in
particular has been widely attacked for
violating international norms what
international norm the one under which
in 1981 Israel was universally condemned
even the Reagan administration joined in
the condemnation of the Security Council
for preemptively destroying the
österreich nuclear reactor does anyone
today you doubt that it was the right
thing to do both strategically and
morally
[Applause]
in a world of the terrorists terrorist
states and weapons of mass destruction
the option of preemption is especially
necessary in the bipolar world of the
Cold War with a stable non-suicidal
adversary deterrence could work
deterrence does not work against people
who ache for heaven it does not work
against under terrible's and it does not
work against undetectable x'
non-suicidal ennemy regimes that might
attack through clandestine means a
suitcase nuke or anonymously delivered
anthrax against the both on datura boast
and undetectable preemption is the only
possible strategy if anything the
doctrine of preemption against openly
hostile States pursuing weapons of mass
destruction is an improvement on
classical deterrence traditionally we
deterred the use of weapons of mass
destruction by the threat of retaliation
after we'd been attacked and that is too
late the point of preemption is to deter
the very acquisition of weapons of mass
destruction in the first place
whether or not Iraq had large stockpiles
of weapons of mass destruction the very
fact that America over through the
hospital regime that had repeatedly
refused to come clean on its weapons has
said precisely this deterrent effect we
are safer today not just because Saddam
is gone but because Libya and Iran and
the others contemplating trucking with
weapons of mass destruction have for the
first time seeing that it carries a cost
a very high cost
[Applause]
yes of course imperfect intelligence
makes preemption problematic but that is
not an objection in principle it's an
objection in practice
indeed the objection concedes the
principle we need good intelligence but
we remain defenseless if we Abdulle the
option of preemption the other great
objections of the way American unipolar
power has been wielded is its
unilateralism I would dispute how
unilateralis we have been we have been
not nearly enough for my taste but no
matter look of course one acts in
concert with others if possible
it's nice when others join us in the
breach no one seeks to be unilateral the
lateral ISM simply means that one does
not allow oneself to be held hostage to
the will of others
[Applause]
irving kristol once explained why he
preferred the Organization of American
States to the UN in the OAS UCB can only
be insulted in three languages thereby
saving interpreters fees of course you
build coalitions when possible we
garnered a Coalition of the Willing for
Iraq which included substantial allies
like Britain Australia Spain Italy and
much of Eastern Europe France and
Germany made clear from the beginning
that they would never join the over-over
throw of Saddam therefore the choice was
not a wide coalition versus a narrow one
but a narrow coalition versus none there
were serious arguments against the war
in Iraq but the fact that France did not
approve was not one of them
realists choose not to be gulliver in an
international system with no sovereign
no police no protection where power is
the ultimate arbiter and history has
bequeathed us unprecedented power we
should preserve that power and our
freedom of action to use it but here we
come up against the limits of realism
you cannot live by power alone realism
is an antidote to the woolie
internationalism of the 90s but realism
can only take you so far it's basic
problem lies in its definition of
national interest as classically offered
by its great theorist Hans Morgenthau
interest defined as power cube organ
thought postulated that what drives in
nations where drives are foreign
policies is the will to power to keep it
and expanded for most Americans the will
to power may be a correct description of
the world of what motivates other
countries but it cannot be a
prescription for America it cannot be
our purpose America cannot and will not
live by rail politic alone our foreign
policy must be driven by something
beyond power and unless conservatives
present ideals to challenge the liberal
idea of an international community they
will lose the debate
[Applause]
which is why among American
conservatives another more idealistic
school has arisen that sees America's
national interest as an expression of
its values it is this fourth school that
has guided foreign policy in this decade
this conservative alternative to realism
is often lazily and invidiously called a
neoconservatism but that is a very
arguing for a school whose major
proponents in the world today are George
W Bush and Tony Blair if they are
neoconservatives than I'm a liberal
there's nothing neo about the bush and
there's nothing con about Blair yet they
are the principal proponents of what
might be called democratic globalism a
foreign policy that defines national
interest as power but his values and
that identifies one supreme value where
John Kennedy called the success of
Liberty as George as president of Bush
put it in his speech at Whitehall last
November the United States and Great
Britain share a mission in the world
beyond the balance of power or the
simple pursuit of interest we seek the
advance of freedom and the peace that
freedom brings beyond power beyond
interest beyond interest defined as
power this is the credo of democratic
globalism which explains its political
appeal America is a nation uniquely you
built not on blood or race but on a
proposition to which it's sacred honor
has been pledged for 200 years this
American exceptionalism explains why non
Americans find this foreign policy so
difficult to credit why Blair has had
more difficulty garnering support for it
in his country and why Europe in
particular kinds finds this kind of
value driven foreign policy hopelessly
and irritatingly moralistic
Democratic globalism seizes the engine
of history not the will to power but the
will to freedom and while it has been
attacked as a dreamy idealistic
innovation its inspiration comes from
the Truman the doctrine of 1947 the
Kennedy inaugural of 1960 and Reagan's
evil empire speech of 1983 they all saw
to recast a struggle for power between
two geopolitical tightens into a
struggle between freedom and unfreedom
and yes good and evil which is why the
Truman Doctrine was heavily attacked by
realist like Hans of Morgenthau and
George Kennan and Reagan attacked by the
entire foreign policy establishment for
the sin of ideologized the Cold War Inge
by injecting a moral overlay that was
then today post 9/11 we find ourselves
in a similar existential struggle but
with a different enemy not Soviet
Communism but Arab Islamic
totalitarianism both secular and
religious bush and Blair are similarly
attacked for naively and crudely casting
this struggle as one of freedom versus
unfreedom good versus evil
now given the way not just freedom but
human decency were suppressed in both
Afghanistan and Iraq the two major Wars
of this new war you would have to give
the Bush and Blair's moral claims the
decided advantage of being obviously
true nonetheless something can be true
and still be and still be dangerous
many people are deeply uneasy with the
Bush Blair doctrine I dare say many
people in this room today when Blair
declares in his address to Congress the
spread of freedom is our last line of
defense and our first line of attack
they see a dangerously
passive-aggressively utopian
foreign-policy in short they see Woodrow
Wilson now to a conservative Woodrow
Wilson is fighting words yes
this vision is expansive and perhaps
utopian but it ain't wilsonian Wilson
envisioned the spread of democratic
values through has yet to be invented
international institutions he could be
you're forgiven for that in 1918 there
was no way to know how utterly corrupt
and useless these international
institutions would turn out to be hey
[Applause]
[Music]
eight decades of bitter experience later
with Libya chairing the UN Commission on
Human Rights there is no way not to no
democratic globalism is not Wilsonian
its attractiveness it's precisely that
it shares realisms insights about the
centrality of power its attractiveness
is precisely that it has appropriate
contempt for the fictional legalisms of
liberal internationalism
moreover democratic globalism is an
improvement over realism what it can
teach realism is that the spread of
democracy is not just an end but a means
an indispensable means for securing
American interest the reason is simple
democracies are inherently more friendly
to the United States less belligerent to
their neighbors and more inclined
towards peace realists are right that to
protect your interests you often have to
go around the world bashing bad guys
over the head but that technique no
matter how satisfying has its limits at
some point you have to implant something
something organic and that something is
democracy but where the danger of
democratic globalism is it's
universalism it's open-ended the
commitment to human
freedom its temptation to plant the flag
of democracy everywhere it must learn to
say no and indeed it does say no but
when it says no to Liberia or Congo or
Burma or cap menses alliances with
authoritarian rulers in places like
Pakistan and for that matter Russia it
stands accused of hypocrisy which is why
we must articulate criteria for saying
yes and I propose a single criterion
where to intervene and greater bring
democracy where to nation of build where
it counts call it democratic realism and
this is its axiom we will support
democracy everywhere but we will only
commit blood and treasure in places
where there is a strategic necessity
meaning a place central to the larger
war against the existential enemy the
enemy that opposes a global mortal
threat to freedom where does it count 50
years ago Germany and Japan that counted
why because they were the seeds of the
greatest global threat to freedom in
mid-century fascism and they were turned
into the bulwarks against the new next
great threat the Soviet Union and Soviet
Communism where does it count today
where the overthrow of radicalism and
the beginnings of democracy can have a
decisive effect in the war against the
new global threat to freedom the new
existential enemy the Arab Islamic
authoritarianism that has threatened us
both in its secular and religious
reforms for the quarter century since
things iike many a Revolution of 1979
establishing civilised decent
non-belligerent pro-western policies in
Afghanistan and Iraq and ultimately
their key neighbors would like the
flipping of Germany and Japan in the
forties changed the strategic
in the fight against Arab Islamic
radicalism yes it may be a bridge too
far
realists have been warning against the
hubris of thinking we can transmute an
alien culture because of some postulated
natural and universal human will to
freedom and they may be right but how do
they know in advance half a century ago
we heard the same confident warnings
about the imperviousness of democracy
and Confucian culture that proved
stunningly wrong where is it written
that Arabs are incapable of democracy
yes the under to undertaking as in
Germany and Japan is enormous ambitious
arrogant and may not succeed but we
cannot afford not to try there is not a
single remotely plausible alternative
strategy for attacking the monster
behind 9/11 it was not Osama bin Laden
it's the cauldron of political
oppression religious intolerance and
social ruin in the Arab Islamic world
oppression transmuted and deflected by
regimes with no legitimacy into
murderous anti Americanism it's not one
man it's a condition it will be nice to
find that man and to hang him but that's
the cops and bobbers law-enforcement
model of fighting terror that we tried
for twenty years and that gave us 9/11
this is war and in war arresting
murderers is nice but you win by taking
territory and leaving something behind
[Applause]
the other unipolar power and what do we
do in August 1902 a vid Hilbert gave a
speech to the International Congress of
mathematicians naming 20 still unsolved
mathematical problems be Queens by the
19th century to the 20th only three
remained by the way but the soup is
getting cold so that's for another night
had he presented the great unsolved
geopolitical problem bequeath of the
20th century one would have stood out
above all the rise of Germany and its
accommodation within the European state
system similarly today at the dawn of
the 21st century we can see clearly the
two great geopolitical challenges on the
horizon the inexorable rise of China and
the coming demographic collapse of
Europe both of which will irrevocably
alter the occult equilibrium of the
international system but these problems
come later
therefore mid-century they are for the
young people here tonight and we won't
even get to these problems unless we
first deal with our problem and our
problem is 9/11 and the roots of Arab
Islamic and nihilism 9/11 felt like a
new problem but for all its shock and
surprise it is an old problem with a new
face 9/11 felt like the initiation of a
new history but it was a return to
history the history of radical
ideologies and existential enemies the
anomaly is not the world of today the
anomaly was the 90s our holiday from
history it felt like peace but it was an
interval of dreaming between two periods
of reality night
9/11 9/11 woke us up it startled listen
to thinking that everything was new it's
not what is new is what happened not on
9/11 but ten years earlier on December
26 1991 the emergence of America as the
world's unipolar power what is unique is
our advantage in this new struggle and
advantage we did not have during the
struggles of the 20th century it's a
question for our time is how to press
this advantage how to exploit our
unipolar power how to deploy it to win
the old new war that exploded upon us on
9/11 what is the unipolar power to do
for schools for answers the
isolationists wants simply to ignore
unipolarity pull up the drawbridge and
defend fortress America alas the
fortress has no moat not after the
airplane the submarine the ballistic
missile and that's for the drawbridge it
was blown up on 9/11 then there are the
liberal internationalists they like to
dream and to the extent they are aware
of our unipolar power they don't like it
they see it's used for anything other
than humanitarianism or reflexive self
defense as an expression of national
selfishness and they don't just want us
to ignore our unique power they want us
to yield it piece by piece by subsuming
ourselves in a new global architecture
in which America becomes not the arbiter
of international events but a good and
tame international citizen and then
there is realism which has the clearest
understanding of the new unipolarity and
its uses unilateral and pre-emptive if
necessary but in the end realism fails
because it offers no vision it is all
means and no ends it cannot adequately
define our mission
hence the fourth school democratic
globalism it has in this
decade rally the American people to a
struggle over values it seeks to
vindicate the American idea by making
the spread of democracy the success of
Liberty the ends and means of American
foreign policy I support that I applaud
that but I believe it must be tempered
in its aspirations universalistic
aspirations and rhetoric - from a
democratic globalism to a democratic
realism
it must be targeted focused and limited
we are the Friends of all but we come
ashore only where it really counts and
where it counts today is the Islamic
crescent stretching from North Africa to
Afghanistan my friends in October 1962
for 13 days we came to the edge of the
abyss then accompanied by are equally
shaken adversary we drew back on
September 11 2001 we saw the face of
Armageddon again but this time with an
enemy that does not draw back this time
with an enemy that knows no reason with
that the only difference between now and
then our situation would be hopeless but
there is a second difference between now
and then the uniqueness of our power
unrivaled not just today but ever and
that evens the odds the rationality of
the enemy is something beyond our
control but the use of our power is
within our control and if that power is
used constrained not by illusions and
fictions by only but but only by the
limits of art of our mission which is to
bring a modicum of freedom as an
antidote to nihilism we can and we will
prevail thank you very much
[Applause]
you
[Applause]